>>> KAITLAN THERE'S A LOT TO
DISCUSS, A LOT OF MONDAY MORNING
QUARTERBACKING, AND ALSO IN
GEORGIA THIS COULD GO TO RUNOFF
SO WE MIGHT NOT KNOW FOR WEEKS.
>> IT COULD BE WEEKS.
AT LEAST IT'LL BE IN DECEMBER
THIS TIME AND NOT JANUARY.
WHO BETTER TO DISCUSS THIS THAN
GEOFF DUNCAN, THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR OF GEORGIA.
DO YOU THINK A RUNOFF IS GOING
TO HAPPEN?
>> STATISTICALLY IT LOOKS LIKE A
RUNOFF.
ONLY A HANDFUL OF VOTES LEFT, I
THINK 4% IN THE METRO AREA.
SO IT FEELS LIKE A RUNOFF.
YOU SAID YOU WERE NOT GOING TO
VOTE FOR HERSCHEL WALKER OR
RAPHAEL WARNOCK.
DOES THAT CHANGE IF THE BALANCE
OF POWER IN THE SENATE DEPENDS
ON THIS RACE?
>> MY ANSWER WAS I DIDN'T
RESPECT HERSCHEL WALKER YET AND
HE DID NOT EARN MY VOTE AND I
WAS NOT GOING TO VOTE FOR
RAPHAEL WARNOCK.
BUT WE HAVE FOUR WEEKS.
I THINK A LOT OF REPUBLICANS ARE
WAKING UP THIS MORNING WHAT
COULD HAVE BEEN.
WHAT COULD HAVE BEEN IF WE
PICKED A BETTER CANDIDATE, THAT
COULD HAVE PUT REAL IDEAS OUT
THERE.
>> AND BRIAN KEMP HAD THIS
VICTORY DESPITE THE FACT THAT
TRUMP ONCE PREDICTED HE WAS
GOING TO GO DOWN IN FLAMES AT
THE BALLOT BOX.
WHAT MESSAGE DOES THAT SEND, DO
YOU THINK?
>> I THINK IT SENDS A MESSAGE TO
THE COUNTRY, ALONG WITH OTHER
STATES, THAT THIS IS A PIVOT
POINT FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THIS IS A TIME THAT DONALD TRUMP
IS IN THE REAR VIEW MIRROR AND
IT'S TIME TO MOVE ON WITH THE
PARTY, CANDIDATE QUALITY.
TURNS OUT MITCH McCONNELL KNEW
WHAT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT WITH
CANDIDATE QUALITY.
WE SAW IT IN GEORGIA, IF THEY
WOULD HAVE WOKE UP 12 MONTHS AGO
AND TOOK THE LEAD OF WHAT REAL
REPUBLICANS AND REAL REPUBLICAN
POLICIES MATTERED WE'D BE IN A
DIFFERENT PLACE.
>> WE'RE WAITING TO SEE WHO
CONTROLS THE HOUSE, TOO.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S GOING TO BE
REPUBLICANS.
DO YOU THINK TRUMP HAD THE WORST
NIGHT BY FAR OF ANYONE ELSE LAST
NIGHT?
>> I WOULDN'T WANT TO DELIVER
HIM THE NEWS LAST NIGHT OR THIS
MORNING OF THE CANDIDATES THAT
THEY SUPPORTED.
BUT IT'S TIME TO TURN THE PAGE,
I'M READY TO MOVE ON.
I THINK DONALD TRUMP'S MOVING
FROM A MOVEMENT TO A DISTRACTION
FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY NOW.
>> WE'LL SEE IF OTHERS AGREE.
HE HAD A HOLD ON THE PRIMARY
VOTERS JUST NOT THE GENERAL
ELECTION VOTERS.
HE WAS NOT IN GEORGIA FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL WEEKS, NEITHER WAS
PRESIDENT BIDEN NOTICEABLY.
DO YOU THINK THAT CHANGES IF
THERE'S A RUNOFF, WILL WE SEE
PRESIDENT BIDEN OR FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN GEORGIA?
>> IT WAS ACTUALLY MONTHS.
I DON'T THINK WE SAW ANY
CAMPAIGN THAT WANTED DONALD
TRUMP OR JOE BIDEN FOR THAT
MATTER.
I DON'T IMAGINE ANYBODY THINKING
THAT DONALD TRUMP WOULD BE A
TAILWIND TO HERSCHEL WALKER'S
CAMPAIGN.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT ANYONE
WOULD THINK THAT WOULD BE THE
CAL
CALCULUS, EXCEPT ONE PERSON,
DONALD TRUMP.
>> IF THERE IS GOING TO BE THE
RUNOFF THEY'RE HOPING TO AVOID
AND WHETHER OR NOT KEMP NOT
BEING ON THE TICKET IF THAT
AFFECTS HOW WALKER DOES.
>> THERE WAS 200,000 FOLKS BY
QUICK MATH THIS MORNING THAT
WERE TICKET SPLITTERS THAT VOTED
FOR BRIAN KEMP AND NOT HERSCHEL
WALKER, VOTED FOR RAPHAEL
WARNOCK.
THIS RUNOFF COULD BE TWO
SEPARATE SCENARIOS, THE BALANCE
OF THE SENATE, HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS POUR IN.
IF IT'S NOT THE BALANCE OF THE
SENATE, IT'S BACK TO SMALL
DONATIONS.
>> I WONDERED IF BRIAN KEMP
HEARD FROM VOTERS THAT WERE
SPLITTING THE TICKET FOR HIM.
HE SAID HE WOULD LEAVE IT TO THE
FOCUS GROUPS.
>> THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
LET'S GO TO CNN'S DATA REPORTER,
OUR SENIOR DATA REPORTER HARRY
INTON AT THE BATTLEGROUND DESK.
HERE'S THE QUESTION.
YOU SAW WHAT HAPPENED WITH
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS,
RESOUNDING VICTORY.
SO DID SUPPORT FOR TRUMP COST
THE GOP VOTES?
>> I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
DOUBT THAT IT DID, DON.
YOU KNOW, DONALD TRUMP, LET'S
START OFF WITH JUST THE STRAIGHT
FACT.
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT A WELL-LIKED
POLITICIAN.
LOOK AT HOW HIS IS UNFAVORABLE
RATING IS NATIONALLY.
58% UNFAVORABLE.
JUST 39% FAIFVORABLE.
AND LOOK HOW THE VOTERS DECIDED
TO VOTE, OVERWHELMING FOR
DEMOCRATS.
I THINK THERE'S ANOTHER WAY TO
LOOK AT THIS.
ESSENTIALLY LET'S SAY WHO WERE
THE PEOPLE THAT TURNED OUT TO
VOTE AND WHO DID THEY SAY THEY
SUPPORTED BACK IN THE 2020
ELECTION.
NORMALLY YOU EXPECT HIGH
REPUBLICAN TURN OUT WITH A
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT.
LOOK HERE, AMONGST THOSE WHO
TURNED OUT TO VOTE, THEY SAID
BACK IN THE 2020 ELECTION, THEY
FAVORED BIDEN 48% TO TRUMP'S
44%.
THAT MARGIN BASICALLY MATCHES
WHAT WE SAW TWO YEARS AGO.
IF WE LOOK AT THOSE WHO SAID
THEY SUPPORTED JOE BIDEN TWO
YEARS AGO, HOW DID THEY VOTE?
IT'S A HUGE MARGIN FOR
DEMOCRATS, 92% TO 7%.
BASICALLY THOSE PEOPLE WHO SAID
THEY VOTED FOR BIDEN TWO YEARS
AGO, STUCK BY THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES FOR THE HOUSE AND
THIS WAS DESPITE THE FACT LOOK
HOW UNPOPULAR JOE BIDEN WAS.
HE HAD JUST A 41% FAVORABLE
RATING.
WHEN YOU PUT IT TOGETHER AND YOU
SAY JOE BIDEN THE INCUMBENT
PRESIDENT IS QUITE UNPOPULAR,
HOW DID DEMOCRATS WIN -- OR AT
LEAST DO BETTER THAN EXPECTED?
THE MINDS OF A LOT OF VOTERS AND
THEY DECIDED WE DON'T LIKE THAT
GUY EITHER.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
STEWART, TO YOU.
MONEY TALKS AND YOU ARE HEARING
FROM BIG REPUBLICAN DONORS ABOUT
WHERE THE MONEY IS GOING.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
DeSANTIS.
IS RON DeSANTIS THE NEXT
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE FOR PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES?
>> HE IS CERTAINLY RISING IN
STATURE AFTER TONIGHT AND BIG
MONEY DONORS ARE TELLING ME
TONIGHT THEY ARE READY TO TURN
THE PAGE ON DONALD TRUMP.
THEY NOW SEE HE IS AN ANCHOR ON
THE PARTY AND THIS IS NOT JUST
PEOPLE THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF TRUMP, THESE ARE
TRUMP ALLIES THAT HAVE PUT BIG
MONEY --
>> THAT'S A CRITICAL DIFFERENCE.
>> IT'S A BIG DIFFERENCE.
THEY'RE REALIZING UNDER TRUMP WE
LOST THE HOUSE, THE SENATE AND
THE WHITE HOUSE AND NOW WE ARE
IN A CRITICAL MIDTERM ELECTION
AND HIS APPOINTED CANDIDATES
HAVE LOST SIGNIFICANTLY.
THE KEY THING WITH THE
DeSANTIS/TRUMP NUMBERS WE SAW
TONIGHT, THAT IS IMPERATIVE AND
IT'S GOOD FOR DeSANTIS, NOT GOOD
FOR TRUMP.
THAT'S A SNAPSHOT IN TIME.
I ALWAYS LIKE TO LOOK AT THE
TRENDS AND YOU LOOK AT THE REAL
CLEAR POLITICS TRENDS OVER THE
LAST FEW MONTHS, DONALD TRUMP
HAS LOST IN HIS NUMBERS AND
DeSANTIS HAS GAINED AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT TRUMP HAS LOST ABOUT
5 POINTS OVER THE LAST THREE
MONTHS, DeSANTIS HAS GAINED.
SO IF THAT TREND CONTINUES, THAT
LEVELS OUT.
PART OF IT IS BECAUSE DeSANTIS
HAS BEEN A PROVEN LEADER, HE IS
A GOOD FUNDRAISER AND NOW HE HAS
RISEN TO THE STATURE OF EARNING
A NICKNAME FROM DONALD TRUMP AND
THAT RIGHT THERE --
>> DESANCTIMONIOUS.
MARIA, I WANT YOU TO TALK ABOUT
THE LATINO VOTE, YOU HAVE BEEN
DIALED IN THIS NATIONWIDE AND
FLORIDA.
FAT KT THAT OUR EXIT POLLS SHOW
THAT DeSANTIS WON LATINO VOTES
BY 13 POINTS AND CONTRAST THAT
WITH THE FACT THAT IN 2020 TRUMP
TRAILED BIDEN ON THE LATINO VOTE
BY SEVEN POINTS, THAT IS A 20
POINT SPREAD, A HUGE SPREAD.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK, AGAIN, LIKE I SAID
BEFORE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS
A LOT OF WORK TO DO WITH THE
LATINO VOTE IN FLORIDA.
DeSANTIS SHOULD BE GIVEN KUDOS
FOR THAT, RIGHT, FOR REACHING
OUT TO LATINOS IN FLORIDA, VERY
SPECIFICALLY, UNDERSCORING THAT
THE LATINO VOTE IS NOT
MONOLITHIC, IT'S VERY DIFFERENT
IN FLORIDA THAN IT IS EVERYWHERE
ELSE, VERY, VERY HAPPY CUBAN
AMERICAN WHICH TRADITIONALLY HAS
BEEN CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN.
I THINK THAT WAS A BIG PART OF
WHAT HAPPENED, BUT THEY ALSO --
DeSANTIS ALSO GOT A LOT OF
PUERTO RICAN VOTERS AND THAT IS
TRADITIONALLY A DEMOCRATIC --
EXACTLY.
BUT I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT WHAT ALICE SAID, SHE
TALKED ABOUT REALLY BIG DONORS
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT, BUT I
THINK THE CHALLENGE FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS DONALD TRUMP
MAY NOT CARE ABOUT THE BIG
DONORS BECAUSE HE HAS THIS LIST
THAT IS LIKE A GAMILLION
PEOPLE --
>> THAT'S A NEW ONE.
THAT IS A NEW WORD THAT COMES AT
5:40 IN THE MORNING.
>> -- THAT GIVE HIM $5, $30,
$100 AND AS LONG AS HE HAS THAT
I DON'T THINK HE'S GOING TO FEEL
BEHOLDEN TO BIG DONORS.
>> IF WE COULD PULL UP ON THE
SCREEN WHAT SCOTT JENNINGS, A
CNN CONTRIBUTOR BUT ALSO
REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST VERY CLOSE
TO MITCH McCONNELL TWEETED
TONIGHT, HOW COULD -- THIS IS
WHAT HE WRITES, HOW COULD YOU
LOOK AT THESE RESULTS TONIGHT
AND CONCLUDE TRUMP HAS ANY
CHANCE OF WINNING A NATIONAL
ELECTION IN 2024?
AS A REPUBLICAN FORMER MEMBER OF
CONGRESS WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I'VE BEEN SAYING THIS.
I HAVE BEEN SAYING THIS OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND THIS IS JUST FROM FACTS AND
EVIDENCE THAT YOU HAVE SEEN PLAY
OUT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT RON
DeSANTIS HAS DONE IS THAT HE HAS
SPOKEN -- HE'S ACTUALLY TAKEN
THE CUE FROM THE GLENN YOUNGKIN
BOOK, PLAYBOOK.
HE IS ALL ABOUT FLORIDA ALL THE
TIME EVERY TIME YOU SEE HIM.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE LOCAL
POLITICS, ALL ABOUT CARING MORE
FOR THE PEOPLE YOU REPRESENT
THAN THE PERSON THAT YOU THINK
REPRESENTS YOUR PARTY.
IT'S, AGAIN, FOLLOW -- PEOPLE
PUT WAY TOO MUCH CREDIT AND
EFFORT INTO A PERSON BECAUSE
THEY THINK THAT THAT'S THE
LEADER OF THE PARTY.
WHY NOT HOLD TRUMP BEHOLDEN TO
THE PRINCIPLES AND THE PLATFORM
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY?